[Music]
like where I live
Rachel Valley we can find me to be best
friends IRL I'll see you soon
see you soon Wow this is incredible hey
Spencer I saw you with the lockers you
okay good bits of a Piper if Spencer
seems zombified Sam oh I'm good he's
fine
something weird is happening to the top
students here kids turn to lifeless
zombies secret passages we have to
investigate hello
maybe it's on a person behind this
something's been following us
I can feel it ghosts don't exist Griffin
is up to something
he has to be behind this well I have
something it was a ghost a buyer ghost
boo I need to bust into that locker or
we could do something that won't lead to
certain danger just an idea
this robot engine is totally stable
unless it's overheated girl's kitchen
duty and Shane stickers guaranteed to
stop girls from blow things up so what
we just give up no we're a team we can
do this we can do anything
things always work out yes you're
something Griffin's in on this we saw
him go into the Walker same as Spencer
who's behind this
yeah what are you doing here what are
you doing here
I love it that's what they all say
[Music]
Chane case
I'd be a real monster monsters aren't
real we'll see about that
[Music]
he was good
you